in the spring of 2018 teachers unions
had a wave of victories with a string of
red state strikes but summer brought a
major defeat when the Supreme Court
ruled in Janis versus asked me that
agency fees are unconstitutional before
Janis some states compelled non-union
teachers to pay an agency fee to the
Union that represented them in contract
negotiations agency fees have kept
teachers union membership and revenue
high in these states unions have
anticipated this verdict in the words of
one union president they are preparing
to become voluntary organizations in
advance of Janice the NEA projected
significant losses over two years
predominantly in agency fees states well
former agency fee states big losses
after Janice could easily be a game
changer for national teachers unions
which are among the most powerful
interest groups in American politics and
easily the most powerful on education
issues a tight bond with the Democratic
Party has worked for unions it's been
pretty effective blocking unwanted
education reforms and in blocking
attacks on the linchpins of union power
like agency fees however the blocking
that has worked well in legislatures
couldn't stop the Supreme Court now
unions will have to go on offense but
now playing offense will be even harder
because to prove their value to teachers
after Janice unions will have to do more
with less
one path forward is to close ranks as in
New York where unions pushed a state law
that would bar non-members from
receiving full union benefits fair
enough but closing ranks may not be the
best bet at loggerheads with the state
and national NEA over political
endorsements Nevada's largest local took
the radical step in 2018 of dis
affiliating from both and the losses
were staggering perhaps going on offense
will avoid such losses if unions can
build a bigger tent for member
one that is focused on local teachers
concerns first and less on remote
political concerns but what about the
red state strike strategy that strategy
caught fire and non agency fee states
could that be the union's answer after
janice maybe but it will be a tough
strategy to bring to the states long use
to agency fees the red state strike
stood out in part because they were the
first statewide strike since nineteen
ninety but they stood out for other key
reasons first they all had legitimate
statewide complaints to rally around
like statewide salary schedules and
markedly low teacher pay but only
fifteen states set teacher pay at the
state level and three of them just went
on strike
so for most teachers the key rallying
point is a district issue not a state
issue those strikes also confronted low
state education spending
but that isn't markedly low across the
country either another distinction these
strikes were spurred less by unions
which were relatively weak in these
states and more by local teachers who
started Facebook groups that quickly
grew to tens of thousands of members the
Solidarity that galvanized these
grassroots movements of teachers next
door will be harder to come by for
unions easily pegged as special
interests and here is where unions and
agency fee states may prove victims of
their own successes agency fee states
tend to have higher salaries and
education funding leaving them without
salient issues for teachers to rally
around unions will have a hard time
using the red state strike playbook in
the very States they expect the heaviest
losses so it sounds like unions are dead
huh well not quite they'll be smaller
the question is if they'll be a lot
different
while hard times may be coming at the
state and national levels Janice doesn't
alter the basic reasons teachers join
unions to organize around their common
interests and have a seat at the local
bargaining table so the most pertinent
question may be what will change at the
local level particularly in agency fee
states most locals will get smaller but
smaller you
can take a few different forms here's
four possibilities first many will lose
their least committed members leaving
their more ardent supporters to push for
more strident positions for instance
groups like the badass teacher
Association push locals to be more
confrontational where such groups become
dominant expect less stable and more
contentious education politics second
many shrinking locals won't become more
strident but may go dormant until new
adverse state or district policies
awaken a resurgence that's a likely
pattern in agency V states accustomed to
bargaining advantages that policymakers
may now aim to pare down
however this pattern could push unions
once powered by agency fees to refocus
squarely on local issues third other
locals could go for a bigger tent taking
a page from the red state strike
playbook some locals could shed the
strong association with union
headquarters and Democratic Party
priorities they could remove party lines
to attract a broader coalition of active
members that route wouldn't make local
politics less contentious but it would
Center them on local teachers shared
priorities potentially leading to more
representative and more durable local
unions finally some locals might just
fade away the red state strikes suggest
that today there are alternative means
of organizing which could compete for
the right to exclusively speak for
teachers Janice could crack the virtual
monopoly unions have representing one of
the nation's largest workforces school
districts will have to bargain and
teachers will be represented on the
other side of the table how unions
evolve and whether new entrants come on
the scene only time will tell but Janice
will amount to a historic change in how
teachers organize what do you think will
happen to teachers unions after the
Janice verdict let us know in the
comments below and check out the links
to my work on Janice in the description
also let us know what other topics you'd
like a EEI scholars to cover on what-if
and be sure to subscribe for more videos
and research from a
I